a new rag doll solver the glottis but
last if these phrases sound intriguing
to you and you like learning about what
people were going through when they
created something then you should really
try out some video game developer
commentaries because that's where these
choice bits originated and he had to put
this thing called the lattice on his
butt Grim Fandango remastered came out
this weekend along with updated graphics
sound and you know it actually working
on modern gaming devices it features
commentary from the developers so this
was the first scene in the game that we
ever actually did with some test assets
some of it is rather random but others I
found myself completely excited to learn
about the guy who lobbied super hard to
get five percent of the CPU so he could
run reverb effects in real time yeah it
brings this whole other world to life
behind the game that means so much to me
it's pretty rad and it's not such a
widespread thing that happens in the
greater gaming universe not like blu
rays and dvds which were basically my
film school games haven't adopted this
feature as a must-have thing yet but
here are some games that do it well if
you are on the look after in the next
steam sale or something pretty much all
valve news remember that little half
like to add on where valve showed up
updates to its source engine and it's
sick new HD or winter I walked into a
dark I believe this was the person
without putting commentary nodes into
their games and each one's sins has
featured these shiny speech bubbles I
was enraptured at the time when I took
these in for the first time because
there just wasn't this much direct
access to developers and insights at the
time but going back to it now the
recordings are very stiff and very
compartmentalized some are still really
fascinating as if you're at a private
panel of GC your site it's all the Alan
Wake collector's edition if you enable
commentary in the extras menu every so
often a little box shows up with a
glossy lit developer awkwardly speaking
about aspects of the game some of it
completely useless its a bright and
beautiful place to stop for a while and
have a cup of coffee but others offer
some nice insights about the setting
gameplay and some remedy history which
getting to know anything about remedy is
exciting as they are the developers of
one of my personal favorites Max Payne
and the upcoming quantum break mark the
ninja features text only commentaries
that are insightful about the
development decisions and specifics on
map creation it comes as an add-on in
the special edition DLC pack but you
know who wants to read the best and most
comprehensive of the
is the deus ex human revolution
director's cut commentary enabled from
the extras menu and they just start up
right from the first cutscene and most
others throughout the game with
subtitles and photos from who's talking
it's very natural comprehensive and they
run down a lot of narrative devices they
weave in and little stories of stuff
that was left out then during gameplay
moments the commentary comes through
when you stand in the right spot as an
incoming transmission that you toggle
they go on and on about production of
the game and hearing about how difficult
it was to have a scientist should be
pushed over a railing and scripted
sequence it really hits home how
granular and challenging triple-a
development can be it's likely to be
such a small percentage of players who
consume content the publishers don't
commit the effort to produce
commentaries let alone well Paige the
major state but if there's a demand here
hopefully it's something that will
become a necessary a certain DVD series
commentaries like futurama for example
but what do you guys think do you even
care Jeff any other favorites I mean let
us know and things watch you remember
the visual impact of those red laser
beams the original intention of the item
was to increase the accuracy of the guns
but the more valuable benefit was
accidental you can now see where the
other members of your team are aiming
you